I welcome to mastering the middlegame
insert generic Feingold joke Here I am
filling in for Ben he's he's working
over at the movie theater and whatever
he does on Tuesday nights like it's
better not to ask questions that guy
alright but tonight I thought we'd go
over some middle games just last night
we had the Monday night mayhem
tournament so the first game we're gonna
go over our very own Danny Machuca was
taken on Darian and this was a very
important game for the the tournament
standings it was the last round
whoever won this got an entry for
himself and a partner to the two-on-two
team championship that's coming up a
team event should be a lot of fun and
whoever wins this got to get to pick a
partner did Danny pick you do you have
some sort of pre agreement he mentioned
maybe we'll do some sort of pre
agreement because he was scared and it's
yeah Danny and Arian are almost exactly
the same rating who's higher rated he oh
he like he really is like a lot aren't
you guys you're both like within 20
points aren't you something like that
and they play all the time and as usual
whoever's wedding first loses that's
that's like they're at the running theme
and so this game
Danny was was ahead in the tournament he
had a three points Darian had two but I
I told Danny from the start if Darien
wins this game he wins the head-to-head
tiebreaks
and it's not rated tournament so I just
do whatever I want so it's it's yes the
greatest tournament to direct ever like
if you ever want to do crazy stuff when
you're tournament director but you
realize they'll like take your
certificate away this is the tournament
wanna do it yeah I've made Danny play
like three people at once I've given him
all sorts of time odds and PISA like I
make it you know it used to be Danny
would be the only like strong player to
show up for it now it's it's a lot more
balanced so I don't pick on him as much
you know when he's playing someone
thousands I handicapped a game a little
bit
and that's what that's what the mayhem
is all about and in this game it was
it's a thematic tournament so they had
to play the brayer that's what we just
talked about last night and we've
already talked about it so we'll jump
through the opening you already know the
opening tonight we'll learn the
middlegame so in this position we reach
the brayer and since Darian went to my
class for a longer duration
I let him pick the color and for some
reason he picked black and in my mind I
already assumed that Danny was black so
I already made a big mistake because I
know Danny and I know he likes to play
d3 here which we didn't even talk about
we talked about it for like one second
in the lecture so I should have put them
with d4 on the board at the start of
this game
there's and Danny went here ruining the
entire lecture prep and well he got a
penalty you know cost him 12 minutes
playing d3 and he knows what he did he
knows he's supposed to play d4 to fit in
with the lecture oh it's fine yeah it's
fine yes fine yeah Magnus plays d3 all
the time in these positions if Reinfeld
no I mean it's fine
but but Danny knows it was like
intentionally to get out of the whole
lecture he knows what he did anyway
and you're supposed to be here so I
could really yell at him but uh okay and
it's better to when the people are in
the room I don't know what Daniels okay
so you played D 3 and now Darien is all
on his own
but at least Darien and Danny do what
nobody else does in this tournament like
I tell them how to maneuver their pieces
and then they do that everybody else
like they go sit through the whole
lecture and then they play some game and
they play like something completely
random and they don't they just ignore
the entire lecture but in this game he
decided to play the move c5 which is
very common when they have a pawn on d4
because then they sorta have to do
something with the tension in the center
usually if they end up playing d5 and
then you can play see four and the
knight can maneuver to d7 c5 but it's a
little bit different here and the main
line in this position is actually Knight
B to d7 and the fact that the pawn isn't
on d4 means
sometimes the night can go to c5
immediately so this it has a much
different character than the d4 lines
already so Danny does the Roy Lopez
maneuver this is his his plan here the
Knights going over here he'll eventually
attack on the Kings side typical Rema
nuvaring for black is as such you know
so okay these are these were discussed
in the lecture so we won't go over too
much but here you can play here and now
this yeah this isn't what was playing
the game this is the the main line of
this position here where you play the
brayer and they play in immediate d3 so
the knight actually can use c5 and it's
quite useful there sometimes it can drop
back it keeps a lot of pressure in the
center it makes it so it's it's hard to
play d4 sometimes because you're on the
e pawn it's a pretty good square for the
knight so the game may continue as such
and you have a typical position for this
type of line but it was it was worth the
the 12 minutes he got he got Darien out
of prep and c5 okay I mean not a bad
move in this structure that's a typical
move and Danny just did the maneuver see
cuz they do with like the maneuvers that
I said they at least do that much this
should be seven then they maneuver they
did all the maneuvers except for here
Danny Rd did something weird so yeah
just the normal move would be playing
Knight to g3 and I think had he done
this he actually gets a really good
position because for example if you play
g6 which I'm not saying is the best you
can run into some trouble that we also
will see in the game where if the knight
comes here you got some pressure here on
f7 so this sort of thing could cause a
lot of trouble so if you just do like
the standard maneuver without thinking
it's it's a little bit different here
for example if you mix it up you play d5
you try to cause some confusion then
after like some moves like this
everybody's confused but just seeing
that uh in this position normally I mean
if you don't play g6 than the knight
goes to f5 so that's the move that you
would like to be able to play but I mean
just seeing this much is enough to
that this should be pretty good for
white I'm not saying it's winning or
anything but it's it's a probably what
Danny should have considered so what
were you gonna play I assume you
calculated this we gonna play g6 sir
yeah undermining the center okay and I
think I haven't defended enough right
now right if I just take care yeah yeah
you were gonna work toward it okay and
yeah because if you again if you don't
just played you say I mean my knight sir
are coming in here pretty fast
yeah the computer puts both the Knights
there and then like all the crazy
tactics like it did checked me too
that's not the computer role so I put my
Knights here and then checkmate but here
g4 was played by Danny so very strange
but we did go over a game where white
played g4 it was much later in the game
here it's okay it's interesting and he
doesn't have this idea I guess he's just
gonna he's gonna play here sometimes
even if you have a pawn on g6 you know
we're gonna sacrifice a knight maybe to
open the G file the King's getting out
of the way the rook goes to g1 as in the
game we saw but this isn't the position
that we were looking at it's completely
different so a little unusual and yeah
this also is a very common idea you
normally you get one night two g3 and
then they they both look here there is
one tactic to keep in mind I'll play I'm
not gonna not gonna play the optimal
move I'll just put here whenever you do
do this you do need to remember that
your knight is not protected so
sometimes they can take this and attack
your knight
so that's just one idea to keep in mind
though sometimes you can even let them
take it and then there's some sort of
like counter tactic not saying in this
position there is but in general there
here there is so if I just go back
if you take the night on d6 is hanging
okay yeah no this is good either but
yeah yeah in general it's a just
speaking in general it's what you want
to keep in mind whenever you put that
night on h4 and it's not protected you
know there's a lot of lot of stuff here
that can sometimes take it so g4 not the
best move
and now the immediacy for I thought this
was a really good move I'd like to let's
move now it just works now because the
nights not on g3 you know if the nights
on g3 then I have before protected
enough and the point is if I take this
then the e pawn is not protected enough
we're attacking it twice as defended
once so he dropped back all right so
yeah we're looking at this this crazy -
crazy move maybe it is too crazy because
uh yeah I can just I can just take here
and take back and even if you play this
it looks like I mean deliberating moving
I'm trying to get in here is d5 so and
that's sort of a theme we saw in the
game like if I get to play d5 then I'm
doing pretty pretty well here and I got
two bishops and you know your King is a
bit exposed over there and you're not
checkmating me so this this looks quite
pleasant for black but Dani I would she
was here cuz he'd be like yeah I didn't
thing was attacked I moved the thing
okay and so the night went here to c5
and you have to protect your epon so
Knight to g3 and now here actually it is
interesting too because here you can
consider d5 and it's crazy
you took the bishop which i think is the
the safe way to get a small edge in this
position so anything I mean I think
practically and for those at home it's
game 45 with a 5 second delay though
after Danny's little d3 incident he
dropped right down to 30 minutes yeah so
that was after his first move
all right so I think yeah this let's
just just look at this I put one line in
here just to get an idea of the
craziness because you have to sort out
all sorts of wild and crazy stuff when
you play this way so this is how I play
against Danny and I think that's why he
doesn't want it ever a wild and crazy
like I will figure everything out right
away and I'll be like yeah it'll all
work itself out and yeah so here this
this line which is one of the many lines
here can lead to all sorts of crazy
stuff after say we take the Queen can
take either the bishop or the knight
okay let's take the bishop and what's
funny in this position and again you
have to sort all of these complications
out in your head is if you take here
what's funny about rook to e3 is that if
you take my bishop on c1 oh yeah I take
your Bishop on f3 and your knight still
trapped and I take your knight on the
next move
that's a funny feature in the position
and okay something like this and black
is up in exchange White has a pawn for
the exchange and very complicated way to
get a slight edge your move was much
safer he played the safer you know human
move and okay I think Lex just better
here you know you got you got two
bishops D pawn isn't incredibly weak
he's not attacking you there's no longer
this the scary Bishop on this diagonal
he do you do have to realize the knight
probably is going to come to f5 in the
future and what did he play here she
played g6
you Knight to d7 also was an option and
then you can put the other night on c5
but g6
now the bishop goes in
okay let's let's not give up an exchange
here and then I think here too he also
played a weird move
he played rook a to d1 which kind of
surprises me because a4 is just so
natural and debris Lopes especially when
you know I'm here and I'm trying to I'm
threatening to win upon so it's even
better than it usually is and I mean if
you have to take on a4 then I'm quite
happy I'll take back and I'll double on
the a file so I think this is sort of
the typical way to play in the spirit of
the opening when you play the Rory Lopez
they put a pond on b5 you play a four I
guess he's trying to get some pressure
on your deep on perhaps trying to
prevent d5 left like d5 then everyone's
confused
so Queen c7 9797 again is an idea by in
Queen c7 it's fine this usually is the
right place for the Queen okay yeah
excellent yeah you're protecting e5
you're getting ready for d5 and
sometimes you can even consider Queen to
c4 with the idea that it positionally
doesn't make sense to take this because
then there's there's a B file pressure
mm-hmm yes yeah yes we had all these
ideas and for that reason I mean is it
perfectly good move I quite like it and
now some some deep prophylaxis King h2
defending against some threat that
doesn't exist I assume he's trying to
play rook g1 and then somehow go here or
and open the G file or something
yeah you're on this same diagonal yeah I
think yeah I think blacks like what are
you winning now are you just like a lot
better
Wow okay yeah it's it's close borderline
when you each one you winning yeah
sometimes when you reach one you're
winning it's it's right there on the
borderline so I mean yeah black is is
really comfortable here I don't know
what King h2 really does I don't think
it's it's d5 coming we brought his rook
in first d5 and everybody's everybody's
confused it's complicated yeah mm-hmm
and I can see why you'd want the rook
here too because in these these lines
very complicated does this work
he's got d6 which kind of happened in
the game and then all sorts of crazy so
though yeah there's all these crazy
stuff and I think I like your way to you
just bring your pieces into the game you
know and now yeah now d5 definitely
works
no it definitely works anyone here but
that's not it's not gonna save them and
I like that I'm pretending to look at
the score sheet even though it's it's
it's in the computer Queen e38 I also
don't really understand like okay you
gotta have the way d5 but now you you
went right to the e-file so you know you
got off of one file but now you're when
everything opens up your this still
isn't the right square for the Queen and
d5
yeah just felt yeah
what was the time situation when you
played d5 all right yeah Danny had about
25 minutes okay Wow Darien had four
minutes as black here okay and that's
also why is he place so fast when he
plays you me he flags like every game
he's like it's the exact opposite
well like it doesn't make any sense he's
a he's a man of many faces
he just doesn't respect your game and
it's funny cuz they play so often they
play in every Friday action quad and
this is this is every game so black is
winning so we know that he's not gonna
win cuz that's that's like that's how it
is well whoever's willing first loses
that's every game and we I guess we only
showed like the darién win games
whenever like we're not taping some sort
of like in-house staff special treatment
okay he took here you know so many so
many good moves and yeah this move was
great this in-between move here yeah
Bishop c5 this is this is excellent
yeah great diagonal you know now the
rook is is looking directly at the e
pawn and I really know where as Queen's
going I know where I went I know where
it went
but and I think here yeah so here I
think he made the blunder
okay so I'll let the class think about
this position so I just attacked the
knight what are you gonna do about it
you know what are you gonna do cuz yeah
this is this is a tough position so it's
understandable with less than two
minutes how you could you could mess
this up you can mess this up with a lot
of time so black to move white just
played Queen to g5 please pass and I'll
take your knight
sure if you want a blender you want to
blend give me your your night because
your intake here and check me and etc
yeah yeah I'm thinking about going here
but me I mean I only gonna know if I
have to but but I will I don't know if I
have to but I will but also wait wait
let me also take it and then this also
looks like I'm gonna meet you pretty
soon yeah that's good yeah that's an
important blender to make any it really
is I mean you you are thinking about
that in this position I mean it's an on
and there's a check what's that what did
happen in the game was Knight to d7 a
blunder and now yeah now it's yeah okay
slow down I mean so what should black do
I mean this is a very tough puzzle here
I mean moving the night away just
doesn't work and part of the thing is
it's not just about having the knight on
f6 once you again you know for we're
trying to think about what our opponents
are planning to do which was the lecture
we had just a minute ago if you're if
your knight moves away what is White's
move here this also might give you a
clue
night two one of the white squares it's
it's one it's one of these it's one of
those these are the suggestions from the
crowd it's it's not f1 that's that's it
but II for excellent yeah this is the
big the big threat so it's not just
about saving the night it's about
controlling efore which means you have
to protect the night so I'm you know I
move like this is blacks best bet he's
still better and he still has all the
same threats that he has in the position
but okay not an easy move to make it's
not easy to make and you know you get
twenty minutes two minutes it becomes
difficult but in the game we're gonna
try to understand why 94 is such a
powerful move here for white alright so
what was played here Bishop e7 and now
White has a winning move already
yeah d6 excellent and white wins so that
was yeah that was the costly thing
giving up control over efore easy to say
in hindsight you just control d4 but
yeah not not very easy to see so in the
game how does he how come like he like
him he can't like find a simple fork
when he plays me then he plays you and
he's like tactical genius like how is he
so different and okay he went here
though this I did see this during the
game and I thought this lost less
material yeah because yeah if you take
care it's just an exchange but I thought
that was the way to lose less material
because yeah no it's no it's a piece
you're out of it yeah it's hard it's
hard to focus here but you know there's
all sorts of ideas now I mean there's
checking and there's this night here and
there's all sorts of and the tactical
god that Danny is just perfect you know
right cuz otherwise 9 f 6 so that makes
sense
you took here
yeah 95 also is interesting too but but
everything everything wins so and then
here and uh Darian gave it up so yeah
he's up a brook and yeah yeah so I mean
I was a tough tough loss and to rub it
in he didn't invite Darian to his two on
two team any of you even bother to show
up he knew he knows I'm talking about
this game right now
I don't know where he knows I'm talking
about this game every day was just gonna
be like the darién loses all of it as
games show but uh but no I mean we
haven't shown games where Darian is one
in the past it's just we don't put those
on YouTube that's like that's not a
YouTube thing and okay I didn't want to
use this time also to go over some of
the games you guys keep sending in games
which is great you can keep submitting
your games to info at st. Louis chess
club org if you want to have your games
featured here and and be brave like
Darian and let us explore your your
games and I find all the faults in them
so this is a game that came from a
gentleman named Chris his I assume as an
Internet rating is a 1706 and he was
playing with the white pieces here
against 1698 but here he said a little
more briefly hi I really enjoy your
videos on YouTube and I noticed that you
asked viewers to send in interesting
games I have one game that finished
recently which I thought ended in a nice
mate please consider this for your next
video I'm white this was a blitz game or
both Queens got traded quickly okay and
we'll get right to it here so so
straight off the bat we get the Philidor
and he played the the most theoretical
move d4 excellent and immediately some
some some funny stuff happened and I
think one of the big problems here is I
mean here white didn't even do anything
about the the threat so white clearly
just misses a threat here the thread is
just to take on e5 twice so I think what
the problem was because I saw this and
this is V five is hanging here for like
several moves in the beginning so we'll
take this one a little bit slower and I
think the problem when you miss
something like right at the beginning
like there's a pawn hanging it comes
just from playing the opening moves so
fast you know it's just memory and then
they do something you don't know and
you're not really thinking about what
the plot was and it takes a little time
to get into the game but it is really
important for move one to already start
thinking about the plot so here you know
you put your pawn on e4 you're grabbing
the center they copy you they you get
their equal share of the center and when
you play Knight f3 you need to be
thinking I'm attacking his pawn because
you know any plays it move like Knight
f6 which is legitimate you take on e5
like that's them your attacks upon so
you take it but if you're not thinking
about that you just play Knight f3 cuz
Juliano it's in a book somebody told me
about Knight f3 and I just play yeah and
you're not thinking about the center
which is the most important thing not
only throughout the game but like the
first couple moves it's all about
controlling the center so that that is
the focal point and so after d4 you need
to realize you're attacking e5 twice you
know so in this position d6 protects the
pawn
d4 attacks it a second time and I think
yeah if you're just you know a little
careless you know you're just not
thinking about it cuz you're playing
just moves from memory you just miss an
opportunity like this I mean I mean here
you take and this also is an important
thing too because this will be relevant
when we see the rest of the game when
the D file opens up and nobody's castled
and you can trade Queens you trade the
Queens because whoever has to take the
Queens if it's blacks turned he takes
and you have to misplace your king or
you can take and you can misplace c4 his
Bishop or his king so normally when the
when the D file is opened you
want to trade the Queens it's different
if you've castled because then you know
the rook might swing to the open file
butter Leon in the game when the D file
opens up you trade the Queen's okay so
it was ignored Knight c3 obviously not a
bad move but missing the chance to grab
a pond alright okay so here we return to
the game and okay so you defend it e4 he
attacked it again and still the e5 pawn
is just there for the taking
and I think now not now would you wait
for it
after c6 I mean perhaps better is Knight
B to d7 because that protects the e pawn
c6 I mean to move you you do want to
play in this position and we got it yeah
okay so D file opens up
nobody's castled you trade the Queen's
but instead here he he took on e5 which
is probably great for white but it does
allow black to take on d1 so you should
take here on d8 and then either way you
take is you know undesirable for you and
now we grab this Ron f7 so black
probably castles or you know and you're
up upon but in the game by taking here
you allow him to misplace your piece
this happens all the time the D file
opens up and okay here you are attacking
f7 but you're in check so you know what
the kids tournament it would be like
here and they'd say is this check me and
here you took with a knight which does
undefended pond although you're on f7 so
he doesn't really have time but this
also occurs too sometimes they take your
queen when the D files open and very
often you have a knight on c3 and the
knight is actually really good there so
it's kind of you want to balance which
piece do you want to misplace and who's
really doing a good job and it is very
common here just to take with the king
your knight is great on c3 Queens are
off the board so okay I'm not gonna
Castle I mean I might be able to just
put my my guy
back here in the future and get my
bishop out and develop my rooks put him
on the open file and you know you should
be relatively safe you can always you
know go go retreat manually which I
think would have been the more accurate
decision because I mean going back with
the night and the night doesn't belong
on d1
you're on f7 which is more important
than any force so he took on e4 yeah I
think you castle okay let's yeah okay
yes so and this also was everything he
did make the right decision here which
way would you guys take on f7 they're
both so so tempting with the bishop
which is yeah this is this is the way to
go
not here and then okay I mean you're
gonna have to retreat notice f2 is
defended though but then you retreat and
a funny thing happened to in one of the
blitz tournaments we had where we
invited GM's to come we had three GM's
play in the tournament
and there was one game where was really
funny like this happened he took with
the bishop and after the king moved well
white castles in the game but uh Bishop
b3 was played and then the next move
like his opponent didn't do something it
was the same setup like he should have
played rook f8 or whatever was in the
position and then like this happened and
the knight got out and then he put
something else where it could be forked
and then I went back in
as in the famous game GM for somebody
yeah so yeah so I think yeah Bishop to
b3 it's the Grand Master Lee move in
this position just threatening the fork
and you they they play rook up to 80
Newcastle and because once you steal the
stuff in their position
you know you eventually this stuff might
end up being pretty loose you know your
Knights not defended your bishops not
defended no immediate threat but just
going back to safety is it's a good idea
here okay castling okay and so he puts
his rook here excellent and and so here
an interesting move I so I think again
this would be three is the way I'd go I
mean okay I stole the stuff I get away
with the crime I leave the scene late c3
which probably isn't altogether bad I
mean you're positionally yeah you're
letting him double the pawns
so it's not like the first thing I would
consider here some people really have a
sour face on their like stuff like some
people can't take it they're like
they're like they're packing up they're
ready an elite like Knight c3 oh no but
it's okay it's okay and this is sort of
the example of the the stuff that can
happen when your stuff becomes loose
like this if they can attack your knight
they can remove the defender of the
bishop bishop a3 he says which was
played next line yeah can't whisk him
can play like Chris rook d1 also is very
strong the in if here here and then yeah
but yeah Bishop III yeah you have to do
something about this he's taking your
knight if he takes your night he takes
your bishop so this is a very good find
and here black ran away which is wrong
yeah that the rook is better here than
here so you should keep your rook here
something like Bishop e7 and we can we
could trade it if you want but yeah not
rotate shape
you didn't go to f8 just to go back to
AJ okay check excellent and then yeah I
wish I was in the kids tournament cuz I
could just play this move and I'd get
away with it that's actually a pretty
good move for them I mean some some of
you didn't see the opening that we saw
those there was some magical moments in
that tournament you got to be here live
to get that the inside scoop on some of
these games they were pretty good so why
did this happen yes this did happen and
okay he's he's going for a little walk
it's all [ __ ] I mean it's it's not
advisable to go back check and you like
here and draw and then repeat okay so I
mean yeah you gotta go to p6 and all of
a sudden Chris plays like a genius it's
great he has the opposite problem then
like everybody else has he got this
position and now he's like a he's a
tactical genius Danny Machuca style and
he plays great and most people it's like
you know they do okay in the opening and
then mil game an endgame that's like a
house to her he's the opposite he did
the opening a little wrong didn't take
the pawn did a couple wrong things in
the opening and now he plays great like
a genius North v1 okay
really strong move really starting move
all of a sudden yeah yeah and so he took
what the pond what what happens here
Brooksie for or do you mean this one
or did you mean that one uh-huh
that's it so yeah you can't take back
with the night so what an amazing move
so instead he took with the pond so we
got that the king cut off from the B
file you know the king has nowhere to go
I played Bishop c4 next excellent and
then he allowed it rather than playing
the much more accurate Bishop to e6 and
only then here getting made it in two
moves rather than one that computer
doesn't want me to play it
Wow yeah fantastic criss-cross got the
rook on the B file all of a sudden out
of nowhere I mean this this great tactic
yes he understands yeah opening the B
file he's got the bishops suddenly it
just became an attack out of nowhere so
yeah you should be really proud of this
move that was that was a good one
okay I think we we have a little bit of
time so we'll well speed through one
more of these Chris actually sent in two
games and another interesting blitz game
I played white with equal ratings
okay so evenly matched and we get Alec
kind and Knight to c3 which is okay it's
the only other viable alternative to the
the mainline with E 5 so this is fine
c6 a bit strange but it's weird and then
he plays d5 so it's it's like a Carl
Khan only it should be black to move
here which makes a big difference
because now I can play e5 it was still
possible to play d6 and play Pierce
style you know Ness this probably would
be fine I'm not a not a huge fan of d5
because it allows me 5 if the knight
drops back you have to calculate e 6 and
ok but he's like I'm gonna be active and
I also chose this game because this also
is a funny story because I had a student
show me this let me let me show you what
happened again so he takes and then he
plays the move that follows my very
specific rule very specific when a
knight takes on e4 and you take back and
they take back with a pond you play c3
because of some Aronian game and then I
show all my students when they get this
sort of position it's a very specific
rule but I have told people before when
you when you make this trade you play c3
alright and now a very interesting thing
happens to so I'm kind of glad we got
this because both sides I think they
were thinking ok this pawn is really
weak but it's actually quite hard for
white to target it it's it's sort of
easy to defend this pawn so after f5 I
think here white made a strategic omus
take he did not check with the Queen I
don't see the point of that move either
but well I think he took here and if I
can if I can read Chris's mind he was
thinking I'll take on passant and then
the e4 pawn is still weak that's my
assumption because this is actually very
similar to a game like a student showed
me only it was like a French defense
much better I think is is just to leave
it where it is and the big problem for
black is he doesn't have a lot of places
to put his pieces it's not not easy to
develop comfortably I mean where's where
are you going even if I play here
where's that dark-squared bishop going I
mean I kind of have like two pieces that
want to use d7 I think if if you instead
play a move like this just I'm not even
gonna let you get your Bishop out now
you just have nowhere to put your Bishop
and I play moves like this I have the
square available to me I mean it's it's
so easy for me to develop my pieces and
castle and if I ever want you to in the
future to get rid of this pawn if I run
play move like f3 I could also undermine
you this way I can leave my knight on G
1 for a second and I think the real
problem is how do you develop as as
black but when you take on
well now the game sort of opens up and I
mean positionally black doesn't have a
good position here I mean okay we
continue now Bishop c4 which is
excellent this is probably the best
square for this piece so little
prophylaxis okay and now another
interesting decision and I think a good
one
now he checks and here I think the move
he played was the best only due to his
opponents response he went back and then
his opponent pushed his pawn and now all
the dark squares are super weak so I
worked out for white but I think
objectively you should probably think
about creeping in here but if I knew my
opponent was gonna play a5 and I'd play
this move the alternative is just to
protect the pond and not allow some of
the bad stuff that happens to happen
all right so we have control over the
dark squares the bishop can go to h6
this guy can can go somewhere you know
black still has to develop his pieces
but he's not gonna do that this game
don't worry about it
what did he play okay an h4 you know I
don't know what the time control was but
if this was a one-minute game then then
excellent if this was game in 60 minutes
then come on boo but it's it's the right
idea h4 h5 it's the right idea
you know I probably would have like
developed my pieces but but black
doesn't develop his pieces either this
is great yeah you gotta go back and I
don't know if he's he's just trying to
prevent Bishop g5 I don't know if he's
trying to take that the pond listen you
think he's trying to take the pond he's
not he's not preventing Bishop g5 he
wants the pond
probably alright and you push this
and we have a threat and black saw it
so g5 alright yeah you're so pathetic
alright well this obviously is fantastic
quite Bischoff t2 I guess he's gonna
Castle and then black to something and
so here yeah he sort of messes up here
too so if he was thinking
prophylactically he was thinking what's
my opponent gonna do next he probably
would have come to a conclusion white is
gonna Castle queenside and so one way to
get a counter play and I'm gonna be
really crazy because that's been my
that's been my style all game is if I
know your castling queenside I kind of
want to be able to play here and I'm
Bishop III go here and just go nuts and
that way I open up stuff on the
queenside and hopefully I don't have to
develop my pieces to attack you or be
cast sold and save like hopefully that
doesn't matter but that that's one
possibility
and after here I mean now you're in the
way of the pawn so you're not gonna do
that and I don't really see what the
Queen is doing on b6 so white is slowly
improving blacks not although the
computer move here is great what's look
computer move here yeah they can be a
rules fantastic well you would never
consider it don't worry about positional
chess
although it's positional move yeah the
computer is like G for that prevents f3
it prevents night h3 g4 and that's the
move everybody would have played yeah
but okay okay and why it is why it's
crushing it and again he has the right
idea here to f3 and okay I'm wise
crushing it but I do again want to
mention the amazing move
what's the computer move here it's it's
fantastic
g4 it's probably a good move
yeah I was thinking about doing that in
like all these positions too but yeah I
don't I don't want to make a move for
black in between a 5 or a row cafe in or
something yeah how come nobody said
Knight to f3
you take why don't we play here you know
you play here GF I didn't give up a
piece to play gf
Queeny five threatening the rook gaining
some time then I can take care and I can
double on the e-file and you know I'm
playing here and I'm taking em getting
my piece back and Knight f3 so ok no
demerits for missing Knight f3 f3 also
very good the center is crumbling blacks
of the center your castled fantastic
he took which is bad and this also
happens to in chess and it's it's kind
of hard but what you need to be thinking
about is not like oh I'm gonna lose a
pond in this but you need to be thinking
well my king is in the center I cannot
let the e-file open up you can't open up
the e-file it doesn't matter you can
have a pawn for example Knight a6
intending to castle with the idea that
if you take how do I not open the e-file
ya therefore yeah the pawn is irrelevant
what matters is King safety and ok so
but in the game you made it even worse
you just voluntarily opened the e-file
and now yeah we got this pin we got we
got this idea going on the knight can
take on f3 just like the computer wanted
to earlier but here it's even better the
files already open so here some legal
move now very excellent play once again
you know he he finishes the game in very
excellent style that's how he rolls the
exact opposite of every single player in
the room opening and then the end yeah
that's funny that's when he shines so
here another great move there's a pin so
in this position takes us
and I think he saw this little trap I
think I don't know I'm trying to channel
my inner Chris here I think he saw this
move and he knew what he was gonna do in
the game ends very shortly here
queen h8 and Bishop f7y a very beautiful
mate fantastic stuff yeah that's a good
one
Wow I mean all the pieces surrounding
the black king and it's the bishop that
gets to deliver them mate excellent
wow that's just great stuff so yeah I
think - my advice for you Chris would
just be sort of in the opening you do
want to pay attention to what's going on
you know especially in the centre and I
think if you you clean up your opening
play a lot you play at the end and you
do tactics and suddenly you're you're a
completely different chess player you
know so you just clean up some of the
opening mistakes and you'll be doing
fantastic so thank you for sending in
the games they're great very
entertaining really nice checkmate to
finish it off some some really good
tactics and yeah keep sending in your
games hit like share subscribe and
thanks everybody for coming out tonight
you